[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
los habitantes de África representan
alrededor del 5% de los inmigrantes en
Estados Unidos pero su población es la
que más crece cada año en 2019 eran 4.6
millones una cifra que podría duplicarse
en 2060 según el instituto del censo
estadounidense muchos de ellos llegan al
país a través del visado de diversidad
más conocido como la Lotería de Visas
para algunos Estados Unidos es la tierra
de las oportunidades un lugar donde
asentar definitivamente a sus familias
para otros es una tierra de paso una
forma de ganar dinero y regresar a sus
países de origen en busca de una vida
mejor pero la realidad es a veces más
difícil mantener el empleo enfrentarse
al racismo y entender la relación con
los afroamericanos forman parte de la
lucha diaria fanialar nos cuenta en el
siguiente reportaje si los africanos que
han vivido en Estados Unidos
consiguieron el sueño americano
[Música]
se va a hacer bien tu seto han pasado
casi siete años desde que me mudé aquí
ya veo quería un cambio porque mi país
todo es muy diferente Es que
así que me dije por qué no vamos a ver
si hay una vida mejor al otro lado
vino a Estados Unidos desde Benin
buscando un futuro mejor a sus 47 años
es conductora de Uber en Washington un
trabajo que nunca se imaginó ejercer
mi papá debe ser revolcándose en su
tumba y preguntándose para qué pagó por
toda mi educación si iba a terminar
siendo taxista antes de emigrar no tenía
nada no sabía inglés
era ejecutiva en una empresa de
comunicaciones aquí conduce entre 12 y
14 horas al día y realiza un promedio de
25 viajes entre Virginia Maryland y
Washington
ese día deja algunos clientes cerca del
Capitolio de Estados Unidos
[Música]
dependiendo del mes y de las horas
trabajadas Hugo gana entre 1000 y 1500
dólares semanales una suma considerable
pero que en Estados Unidos apenas le
alcanza para cubrir sus gastos no le es
posible ahorrar y a veces tiene que
pedirle a su madre que le envíe dinero
desde Benin
es mucho dinero Bueno teniendo en cuenta
el costo de la vida aquí no es nada hay
que pagar el alquiler que ya son 2000
2000 son un millón de francos cfa un
millón de francos cfa por una casa en
Beni sería un palacio cuando uno está en
África piensa que Estados Unidos es el
dorado y no es exactamente así
está fresa
No todos los inmigrantes africanos en
Estados Unidos comparten este desencanto
cada año miles de africanos prueban
suerte del otro lado del Atlántico
[Música]
nacido en vicerta a orillas del
Mediterráneo a sus 24 años decidió que
Su futuro estaría en Estados Unidos hoy
a sus 48 años es el gerente del
prestigioso Georgetown Club en
Washington
los Titanic
en este espacio privado y reservado a
los socios del club también selecciona
los vinos
Hoy hace negocios con una mujer
Marroquín
no sé cómo sé empecé como mesero en Los
Ángeles luego vine aquí trabajé lavando
platos
luego fui jefe de comedor y gerente
general
con el norte de África pero también por
su diversidad Ya que en la capital
estadounidense y sus alrededores
conviven más de 170 nacionalidades
tomé la decisión de ser estadounidense
porque Estados Unidos me lo ha dado todo
por qué no habría yo de retribuirle
también
como dijo el presidente Kennedy
no pregunten Qué puede hacer Estados
Unidos por ustedes sino que pueden hacer
ustedes por Estados Unidos
una decisión de la que nunca se ha
arrepentido en túnez tras la revolución
varios de sus amigos de infancia se
fueron a integrar a las filas del
yihadismo
Tengo dos amigos Un vecino de vicerta
que se fue a Siria y murió allá
y tengo otro en Marsella tunecino su
madre francesa
dejó a su mujer embarazada y se fue a
Siria Bye bye también murió
no tengo nada que hacer en túnez mi vida
está aquí como se dice el último
tránsito de mi vida
alrededor de 20.000 inmigrantes
africanos llegan cada año gracias a la
lotería de la Green Card un sistema
introducido por Ronald Reagan en los
años 80 que permite que los ganadores
vengan a vivir y trabajar a Estados
Unidos Edwin es un camerunés anglófono
que llegó hace cinco años gracias a este
sistema cuando llegué me dije que era el
comienzo de una nueva vida para
participar en la lotería uno de los
requisitos es haber terminado el
bachillerato y haber nacido en un país
con un bajo índice de inmigración a
Estados Unidos Edwin fue seleccionado
tras cuatro intentos preparé todos los
documentos necesarios y entre los
requisitos había exámenes médicos luego
tuve una entrevista en yaunde en la
embajada estadounidense que salió bien
me felicitaron y me dijeron bienvenido
Estados Unidos
a sus 26 años El joven acaba de
graduarse en ingeniería informática de
la Universidad de Maryland es el
principio de muchas posibilidades
me siento muy orgulloso de lo que he
conseguido hasta ahora y es Estados
Unidos el país que lo ha hecho posible
me dieron una oportunidad la aproveché y
estoy infinitamente agradecido
[Música]
traernosa en una zona comercial de
Silver Spring Se ofrece unas horas de
relajación yendo a la peluquería de una
amiga para que le trenza en el cabello
las dos mujeres se conocieron hace siete
años cuando llegó a Estados Unidos y
trabajaban juntas en la misma peluquería
una amistad que creció gracias a un
idioma y unas raíces en común Lilian
también es originaria de África
occidental Aunque África es un
continente es como si fuera un país
sobre todo África francófona tenemos
Prácticamente la misma cultura nos
entendemos comemos prácticamente lo
mismo pensamos de la misma manera
tenemos las mismas experiencias no es el
caso con una mujer afroamericana por
ejemplo
las relaciones entre africanos y
afroamericanos a veces no son fáciles en
los siete años que lleva en Estados
Unidos no ha entablado amistad con
ningún afroamericano
a veces piensas que nuestros antepasados
vendieron a los suyos hay celos porque
cuando venimos aquí sabemos que vinimos
nos buscamos unos a otros luchamos lo
que no siempre es su caso
he trabajado con ellos durante mucho
tiempo Solo tienes que saber cuál es tu
lugar y tomar lo que puedas
la opinión es más severa como resultado
de sus encuentros y experiencias pasadas
es gente que puede acercarse a ti un día
y al día siguiente no son la misma
persona para ello la amistad Es algo
superficial pero para la mujer africana
que soy con la educación que recibí y la
forma en que me criaron la amistad es
Sagrada
integrarse en una sociedad y adoptar sus
códigos requiere resiliencia Esto es lo
que adnan el tunecino Ha logrado hacer
lleva 22 años casado con Rachel una
estadounidense de Virginia Que conoció
aquí su familia es parte de la
materialización de su sueño americano
Estados Unidos me dio la libertad
esa alegría todo me dio una familia
nunca imaginé que tendría una rubia
conmigo
ese era mi sueño también tener una rubia
[Risas]
el francés de Adán a veces no es tan
fluido después de 24 años en Estados
Unidos El tunecino se volvió
completamente estadounidense no del todo
creo que conserva algunos de sus valores
tunecinos
sobre todo en la forma en cómo me guía
no he tenido exactamente el mismo estilo
de vida que mis amigos que son
completamente estadounidenses Tal vez un
poco más recto
Estados Unidos fue fundado por
inmigrantes la familia de Rachel por
ejemplo vino de Alemania a principios
del siglo XX en busca de una vida mejor
la eterna Promesa de Estados Unidos
mi familia ha construido una vida
productiva en este país que es el
resultado de un mil Team pott una mezcla
de personas así que de alguna manera sí
estoy viviendo la continuación del sueño
americano
Edwin el Camerún es también quiere que
este sueño sea una realidad esta tarde
se dirige a Virginia
No puedo decir que el sistema sea
perfecto aquí
pero en cierta medida el sistema es más
favorable que en Camerún
más igualitario
mientras se encuentra un trabajo que
corresponda a su nivel de estudios El
joven trabaja como Dj en eventos una
actividad que le gusta mucho porque
puede compartir sus raíces africanas voy
a poner mucha mascota
música
y también música sudafricana con el
dinero que ha ganado en Estados Unidos
Edwin pudo comprarse el controlador de
sus sueños Este es mi nuevo bebé
lo llamo bebé
porque lo amo
[Música]
El joven no ha vuelto a Camerún desde su
llegada hace cinco años un exilio que a
veces le resulta duro pero del cual no
se arrepiente
todo lo que quiero conseguir lo puedo
hacer aquí
Así que vale mucho la pena
Aunque extraña mi familia a mis amigos y
la comida
pero la nostalgia por su país no afecta
a todos los africanos de la misma manera
la única razón por la cual aguanta Es
por su hija Sasha quien estudia en
Estados Unidos desde los cinco años
me siento más cómoda hablando en inglés
porque cuando llegué aquí olvidé todo mi
francés
llegó inicialmente con una visa de
turista pensando que solo se quedaría en
Estados Unidos unos meses y dejaría allí
a su hija pero su situación personal
cambió
en casa cocina con especias de su país
No puedo vivir sin mi comida africana
o Google le transmite este profundo amor
por venir a su hija que crece entre
estas dos culturas
me siento africana cuando estoy con mi
familia Pero cuando estoy en la escuela
y con mis amigos me siento
estadounidense
espera estudiar en la universidad de
Yale después del bachillerato y
completar el sueño americano de su madre
el sueño americano es posible cuando se
llega joven pero para el 90% de los que
emigraron a Estados Unidos
[Música]
El sueño americano es solo una ilusión
o realidad una cosa es cierta para que
el sueño americano se cumpla no solo hay
que haber soñado con tener una vida en
Estados Unidos también hay que estar
dispuesto a hacer sacrificios
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]